THANK YOU FOR BEING WITH US.
JOINING US NOW IS THE
PRESIDENT OF THE UNITED STATES,
PRESIDENT TRUMP, GOOD TO HAVE
YOU BACK ON THE PROGRAM.
>> HIGH, HIGH, HI, SEAN.
>> Sean: YOU SEEM TO REALLY
LOVE WHAT YOU DID LAST NIGHT,
WHY IS THIS IMPORTANT TO YOU?
THERE IS A PHENOMENON THAT
PEOPLE SHOW UP AT YOUR RALLIES,
WE DON'T SEE THE SAME THING AT
THE DEMOCRATIC RALLIES, WHY IS
THAT IN YOUR VIEW?
>> THERE WAS TREMENDOUS ENERGY
IN THAT ROOM LAST NIGHT.
AND WE HAVE HAD A LOT OF ENERGY
IN VIRTUALLY EVERY RALLY.
IT WAS A SPECIAL ENERGY, I
ANNOUNCED WE ARE GOING FORWARD
WITH THE SECOND TERM AS YOU KNOW
BUT THE LEVEL -- IT WAS LIKE
BEING AT A WORLD CHAMPIONSHIP
COLLEGE FOOTBALL GAME WHERE THE
SCORE WAS TIED GOING INTO THE
LAST MINUTE.
IT WAS THE ENTIRE RALLY.
IT WAS AN INCREDIBLE SCENE AND
OUTSIDE THERE WAS THOUSANDS OF
PEOPLE.
WE WERE ASKING PEOPLE NOT TO
SHOW UP WE WERE SAYING PLEASE
DON'T COME BECAUSE WE HAD
121,000 PEOPLE, THERE WAS
20-25000 PEOPLE IN THE
BASKETBALL COURT WHICH WAS
LOADED UP WITH GREAT, LOVING,
PATRIOTS.
IT WAS AN ELECTRIC EVENING.
>> Sean: I WANT TO ASK YOU, I
DON'T KNOW IF YOU SAW THE SHOW
ON MONDAY, I GUESS IT WAS
TUESDAY NIGHT -- NO, IT WAS
MONDAY.
IT LOOKED LIKE A TAILGATING
PARTY AND PEOPLE THERE, 40, 45
HOURS IN THE POURING RAIN BEFORE
THE EVENT.
I KIND OF REGRETTED NOT GOING
BECAUSE I WANTED TO HANG OUT
WITH THE PEOPLE OUTSIDE BECAUSE
THEY WERE HAVING A BLAST.
>> THEY ARE PEOPLE THAT LOVE OUR
COUNTRY AND THEY LOVE SEEING
WHAT'S HAPPENING.
IT WAS A TAILGATE PARTY FOR THE
COUNTRY.
NOT FOR A TEAM -- ALTHOUGH IT'S
A TEAM WHEN YOU THINK ABOUT IT.
IT'S A TAILGATE PARTY FOR OUR
COUNTRY.
THE FEELING WAS -- IT WAS LIKE
LOVE.
BUT IT'S LOVE FOR WHAT WE ARE
ALL ABOUT, THE THINGS WE STAND
FOR.
IT WAS A BEAUTIFUL EVENING.
EVEN THE ENEMIES, WE HAVE A LOT
OF PEOPLE THAT DON'T LIKE US SO
MUCH, YOU POSSIBLY HAVE HEARD
ABOUT THAT.
>> Sean: I MIGHT HAVE READ
>> THE PEOPLE SAID SOMEONE SAY
THEY NEVER SEEN ANYTHING LIKE
IT.
AND IT WAS POURING, THEY HAD A
MONSOON -- I DON'T THINK ONE
PERSON WALKED OFF LINE.
THEY HAD A RAIN LIKE YOU HAVEN'T
SEEN.
NOBODY LEFT, THEY JUST SAT THERE
AND STOOD THERE AND SOME BROUGHT
TENTS, THEY WERE THERE FOR TWO
DAYS WAITING TO GET IN,
INCREDIBLE EVENING.
>> Sean: I BOUGHT A PAINTING
FROM THIS GUY IN UTAH, HIS NAME
IS JOHN McNAUGHTON AND IT WAS
CALLED THE FORGOTTEN MAN.
I HAVE THE ORIGINAL COPY, I PAID
A LOT OF MONEY FOR IT AND I
BOUGHT IT BECAUSE IT MATTERED TO
ME.
IF YOU RECALL IN 2015-2016 I
TOLD EVERYBODY WITH THE
BIDEN-OBAMA RECORD WAS AFTER
EIGHT YEARS.
I SET AT ALMOST EVERY DAY ON
RADIO AND TV FOR A YEAR,
13 MILLION MORE AMERICANS ON
FOOD STAMPS, 8 MILLION MORE IN
POVERTY, WORST RECOVERY SINCE
THE 40s, LOWEST HOMEOWNERSHIP
RATE IN 51 YEARS, LOWEST LABOR
PARTICIPATION RATE SINCE THE
70s, MORE DEBT THAN 43
PRESENCE BEFORE COMBINED AND
THEY NEVER HIT 1.3     1.3 GDP G
THEY NEVER HIT 1.3     1.3 GDP O
THEY NEVER HIT 1.3     1.3 GDP T
THEY NEVER HIT 1.3     1.3 GDP H
PER YEAR.
YOU TALKED AT LENGTH ABOUT
RECORD LOW UNEMPLOYMENT, THE
BEST SITUATION FROM 1969.
I KNOW THE MEDIA TALKS ABOUT
RUSSIA STILL AFTER FOUR
INVESTIGATIONS, THEY WANT A
FIFTH.
WHAT DOES IT MEAN TO YOU THAT WE
NOW HAVE 2 MILLION MORE JOBS
AVAILABLE THAN PEOPLE WHO ARE ON
UNEMPLOYMENT?
WHAT DOES IT MEAN TO YOU?
>> THE MEDIA ISN'T TALKING ABOUT
RUSSIA SO MUCH, THE MUELLER
REPORT CONCLUDED ON RUSSIA,
THERE WAS NO COLLUSION.
THEY WERE LED TO THE CONCLUSION
BY THE GREAT ATTORNEY GENERAL
THERE WAS NO OBSTRUCTION, IS THE
MOST RIDICULOUS THING I'VE EVER
HEARD.
IT'S A HOAX, A WITCH HUNT, BUT A
HOAX, A WHOLE THING.
GREGG JARRETT SAID IT VERY WELL
WHEN HE NAMED HIS BOOK "THE
RUSSIAN HOAX."
IT'S DISGRACEFUL AND THEY ARE
VERY UPSET NOW, IT DIDN'T TURN
OUT THE WAY THEY THOUGHT.
WE HAD 18 ANGRY DEMOCRATS THAT
HATED TRUMP AND MANY OF THEM
CONTRIBUTED TO HILLARY'S
CAMPAIGN.
IT CAME OUT THERE WAS NO
COLLUSION.
I DON'T HEAR RUSSIA MUCH
ANYMORE, THEY'VE GIVEN UP ON
THAT ONE.
THEY DID SOMETHING THAT IS A
DISGRACE.
I WILL SAY IF THE OTHER SIDE HAD
WON, IF HILLARY HAD ONE, YOU
WOULD INSTEAD OF BEING UP ALMOST
50% SINCE ELECTION, 5 MILLION
JOBS PLUS, THAT'S UNTHINKABLE.
IF I WOULD'VE SAID WE WERE GOING
TO CREATE 5 MILLION JOBS IN TWO
AND HALF YEARS PEOPLE WOULD'VE
SAID RIDICULOUS.
I WOULD HAVE BEEN SKEWERED BY
THE PRESS.
ALL OF THE THINGS THAT HAVE BEEN
DONE, NOBODY HAS SEEN IT.
WE HAVE THE BEST AND LOWEST
UNEMPLOYMENT RATE FOR
AFRICAN-AMERICANS, FOR ASIANS,
FOR HISPANICS, NOBODY HAS EVER
SEEN NUMBERS LIKE THIS.
WE HAVE THE BEST NUMBERS ON
LIVING STANDARDS FOR
AFRICAN-AMERICANS.
THE BEST NUMBERS WE HAVE EVER
HAD IN HISTORY.
SO MANY THINGS, ONE THING AFTER
ANOTHER.
IF THE OTHER SIDE WOULD HAVE
WON, WE WOULD HAVE GONE INTO A
DEPRESSION AND WE WERE HEADED
THAT WAY.
THE RULES AND REGULATIONS, WE'VE
CUT MEANINGFUL REGULATIONS, BUT
IT'S GOT TO BE MEANINGFUL.
IT STYMIED OUR COUNTRY, WE
WEREN'T ABLE TO DO ANYTHING.
JOBS NUMBERS WOULD'VE BEEN A
DISASTER.
INSTEAD WE HAVE MORE PEOPLE
WORKING TODAY, ALMOST
160 MILLION PEOPLE THAN HAVE
EVER WORKED IN THE HISTORY OF
OUR COUNTRY.
THAT'S A GREAT NUMBER.
THE OTHER SIDE YOU WOULD'VE HAD
A CRASH.
>> Sean: I COME FROM
BLUE-COLLAR ROOTS, TEN YEARS IN
THE RESTAURANT BUSINESS, AT 12 I
WAS WASHING DISHES BY HAND.
TEN YEARS IN THE CONSTRUCTION
BUSINESS, EVERY JOB IMAGINABLE.
I IDENTIFY WITH THE FORGOTTEN
MAN AND WOMEN AND I THINK
EVERYBODY IN THIS JOB IN THE
MEDIA ARE OVERPAID AND MOST OF
THEM ARE LAZY.
WHEN YOU THINK BACK ON THOSE
STATISTICS I GAVE YOU,
13 MILLION, 8 MILLION, THOSE ARE
REAL AMERICAN CITIZENS, REAL
LIVES AND NOW THEY ARE REALLY
DOING BETTER.
I THINK ONE OF THE BEST THINGS
THAT IS UNDERSTATED IS WE ARE
FOR THE FIRST TIME IN 75 YEARS
ENERGY INDEPENDENT WHICH MEANS
WE DON'T HAVE TO GO KISSING THE
ASS OF COUNTRIES THAT DON'T LIKE
US.
WE ARE A NET EXPORTER OF ENERGY
AND IF RUSSIA REMAINS HOSTILE,
WE ARE PRODUCE THEM AND WE BRING
THEIR ECONOMY TO ITS KNEES.
>> WE ARE NOW NUMBER ONE IN THE
WORLD AND ENERGY.
IT USED TO BE SAUDI ARABIA, THEN
RUSSIA, NOW IT'S NUMBER ONE AND
AS SOON COME AS SOON AS I GET
THE PIPELINES IN TEXAS APPROVED
WHICH I WILL DO PRETTY QUICKLY,
IT WOULD'VE TAKEN TEN, 15 YEARS.
I'M GOING TO HAVE IT DONE
QUICKLY.
WE COULD INCREASE OUR PRODUCTION
BY 30 AND 40% IN TERMS OF SALE.
THAT'S WHAT WE HAVE DONE IN THE
LAST TWO AND A HALF YEARS HAS
BEEN GREAT.
WE'VE HAD A LOT OF GREAT PEOPLE
AND THEY HAVE WORKED HARD.
THE GREAT PEOPLE OF THE PEOPLE
OF THE COUNTRY, YOU LOOK AT WHAT
WE HAVE DONE, ENERGY ALL OVER.
ALL TYPES OF ENERGY.
LNG, WE ARE THE HOTTEST IN THE
WORLD, THERE'S NOBODY CLOSE.
IT HAS BEEN AN HONOR, WE FREED
IT UP BUT YOU WOULD'VE HAD, I
WOULD'VE BELIEVED, YOU WOULD'VE
HAD A DEPRESSION OR VERY CLOSE
AT THE OTHER SIDE WON.
>> Sean: MR. PRESIDENT ,
DEVIN NUNES WROTE A COLUMN, THE
FORMER RANKING HOUSE MEMBER OF
THE INTEL COMMITTEE, WARNING THE
BIDEN-OBAMA ADMINISTRATION ABOUT
RUSSIAN INTERFERENCE IN THE 2016
ELECTION, HE LAID IT OUT
PERFECTLY IN 2014.
THIS ALL HAPPENED ON THEIR
WATCH, ALL OF IT HAPPENED ON
THEIR WATCH AND MY QUESTION TO
YOU IS THERE REALLY WAS SOME
COLLUSION, THERE WAS RUSSIAN
INTERFERENCE, WE KNOW THAT BUT
WE ALSO HAD A BOUGHT AND PAID
FOR RUSSIAN DOSSIER AND WE
DIDN'T LOOK INTO THAT AND THE
WHOLE TWO PLUS YEARS OF MUELLER,
AND EVEN "THE NEW YORK TIMES"
SUGGESTING IT WAS LIKELY RUSSIAN
MISINFORMATION FROM THE GET-GO,
THE DOSSIER.
WHAT ARE YOUR THOUGHTS ABOUT
THAT?
>> President Trump: I THINK
IT'S A DISGRACE, IT TURNED OUT
TO BE TOTALLY DISCREDITED.
CHRISTOPHER STEELE WAS SUED BY
SOMEBODY, A WEALTHY GENTLEMAN IN
LONDON.
I HEAR WHAT WAS REVEALED WAS
INCREDIBLE, A TOTAL PHONY DEAL.
AND YET THEY DIDN'T LOOK INTO
ANY OF THAT.
ONE OF THE THINGS THAT AMAZES ME
BECAUSE IT'S SO SIMPLE, WHEN YOU
GET RIGHT DOWN TO IT, THE WHOLE
THING IS VERY SIMPLE WHAT
HAPPENED.
THEY WERE SPYING ON MY CAMPAIGN,
USING AGENCIES, INTELLIGENCE
AGENCIES TO DO IT.
GOING AFTER PAGE AND GEORGE
PAPADOPOULOS, WE WILL HAVE TO
FIND OUT IF THEY WERE LISTENING
ON MY CALLS, THAT WOULD BE THE
ULTIMATE.
IF IT HAPPENED WE WILL PROBABLY
FIND OUT.
WE HAVE A GREAT ATTORNEY GENERAL
WHO WAS WORKING VERY HARD AND WE
WILL SEE WHAT HAPPENS.
I LIKE TO STAY UNINVOLVED.
A LOT OF THINGS ARE GOING TO
COME OUT.
IF THEY SPIED ON MY CAMPAIGN AND
THEY MAY HAVE, IT WILL BE ONE OF
THE GREAT REVELATIONS IN HISTORY
OF THIS COUNTRY.
I WILL TELL YOU, IT'S GOING TO
BE VERY INTERESTING, I THINK WE
ARE GOING TO FIND OUT.
CAN YOU IMAGINE IF IT WERE THE
OTHER WAY AROUND AND I SPIED ON
PRESIDENT OBAMA'S CAMPAIGN?
CAN YOU IMAGINE WHAT THE
REPERCUSSIONS WOULD BE?
OR I SPIED ON CRICKET HILLARY'S
CAMPAIGN.
CAN YOU IMAGINE WITH THE
REPERCUSSIONS WOULD BE?
>> Sean: LET ME ASK YOU
SPECIFICALLY, I WANT TO STAY ON
THIS TOPIC BECAUSE I THINK THE
ABUSE OF POWER IS DANGEROUS.
YOU ADDRESSED IT LAST NIGHT.
YOUR CAMPAIGN WAS SPIED ON.
IN OCTOBER 2016, HILLARY'S
DOSSIER, BOUGHT AND PAID FOR
RUSSIAN DOSSIER PAID FOR BY HER
AND THE MONEY SHE CONTROLLED
THAT WAS FUNNELED THROUGH A LAW
FIRM THAT HIRED A RESEARCH GROUP
THAT HIRED A FOREIGN NATIONAL --
WE NOW KNOW THAT BRUCE OHR
TESTIFIED BEHIND CLOSED DOORS
THAT EVERYONE WAS WARNED THAT
CHRISTOPHER STEELE HATED YOU,
THAT HILLARY PAID FOR IT AND IT
WAS NOT VERIFIED.
THAT WAS AUGUST OF 2016.
14 DAYS BEFORE JIM COMEY SIGNED
THE FIRST PHIS APPLICATION AND
I'M TOLD IT SAID THE WORD
VERIFIED ON IT.
FOR HE SIGNED IT HE WAS WARNED
BY KATHLEEN CATHOLIC OF THE
STATE DEPARTMENT WHO MET WITH
CHRISTOPHER STEELE.
MY QUESTION TO YOU IS YOU ARE
SPIED ON AS A CANDIDATE DURING
YOUR TRANSITION, AS PRESIDENT
AND THEN WE HAD STEPHAN HELP HER
SPYING ON CARTER PAGE, SAM
CLOVIS, GEORGE PAPADOPOULOS,
THOSE ARE JUST WAYS WE HAVE
ALREADY VERIFIED, IS NOT IN
DISPUTE ANY MORE.
YOUR CAMPAIGN WAS SPIED ON, YOUR
TRANSITION WAS SPIED ON.
JIM COMEY THREE MONTHS AFTER HE
SIGNED THE WARRANT VERIFYING THE
BULK OF INFORMATION IS TRUE, HE
CAME TO TRUMP TOWER AND TOLD YOU
IT'S SALACIOUS BUT UNVERIFIED,
THE OPPOSITE OF WHAT HE WAS
TELLING THE COURT.
DO YOU BELIEVE THERE WAS A
PREMEDITATED FRAUD COMMITTED
AGAINST FISA COURT JUDGES IN
THESE APPLICATIONS?
>> President Trump: AGAIN,
PEOPLE ARE LOOKING INTO THAT.
IF YOU'RE ASKING MY OPINION I
WOULD SAY ABSOLUTELY YES, IT
WOULD SEEM TO BE YES.
WHEN YOU GET PETER STRZOK AND
LISA PAGE, THE TWO LOVERS WHO
PUT OUT ON THE PUBLIC WAVES,
THEY HAD THE INSURANCE POLICY,
WE HAVE BEEN LIVING THROUGH THE
INSURANCE POLICY SHE WAS GOING
TO WIN BUT JUST IN CASE SHE
DIDN'T WIN, WE NEEDED AN
INSURANCE POLICY.
THAT'S TO SUBVERT GOVERNMENT,
WHAT THEY DID WAS UNBELIEVABLE
THAT THEY COULD DO A THING LIKE
THAT.
THEY REPORTED TO McCABE WHO I
THINK IS A TERRIBLE GUY.
AND THE FBI YOU HAVE SOME OF THE
FINEST PEOPLE IN THE WORLD AND
YOU KNOW THAT AND WE SAT ALL THE
TIME.
I BET YOU IF WE TOOK A VOTE, I
WOULD BE SO HIGH IN THAT POLE,
YOU WOULDN'T BELIEVE IT.
GREAT PEOPLE, I KNOW SO MANY.
THE TOP PEOPLE WERE TERRIBLE,
LEAKERS, THEY WERE LIARS, LOOK
AT THE LEAKING AND THE LYING.
COMEY ADMITTED HE LEAKED, THE
TOP OF THE FBI.
HE LEAKED AND WHEN YOU LOOK AT
WHAT WENT ON, IT'S DISGUSTING.
THE CONCEPT THAT THEY WANTED
INSURANCE POLICY JUST IN CASE
SHE LOSES, WE'VE LIVED THROUGH
THE INSURANCE POLICY.
THE HOUSE COMMITTEE WHICH I
UNDERSTAND TODAY WAS IN A VERY
CLOSE CONFIDENTIAL MEETING WITH
THE WONDERFUL HOPE HICKS, SHE'S
A WONDERFUL PERSON, SHE HAS BEEN
THROUGH HELL.
THEY PUT THIS YOUNG WOMAN
THROUGH HELL, SHE HAS HAD TO PAY
FOR LEGAL FEES AND EVERYTHING
ELSE.
I HEAR THEY WERE TAKING PICTURES
OF HER, TWO CONGRESSMEN IN
PARTICULAR THAT I SEE ON
TELEVISION ALL THE TIME.
I WANT TO MENTION THEIR NAMES,
WE DON'T WANT TO MAKE THEM ANY
MORE FAMOUS.
THEY WERE TAKING PICTURES OF HER
WITH THEIR CELL PHONE AND
LICKING THE PICTURES OF HER
TESTIFYING.
THIS WAS IN A CLOSED ROOM.
IT'S OUT OF CONTROL.
THESE PEOPLE ARE ABSOLUTELY --
THEY USE THE WORD, IT'S A GOOD
WORD, I GUESS -- UNHINGED.
WHAT HAS HAPPENED TO THE
DEMOCRATS AND WHAT HAS
HAPPENED -- WE COULD DO
LEGISLATION TO LOWER DRUG PRICES
SUBSTANTIALLY, EASILY.
WE COULD DO THE THING WE NEED
THE MOST QUICKLY IS BORDER
SECURITY.
WE'VE DONE AN INCREDIBLE JOB BUT
I HAVE TO DO IT MYSELF.
WE CAN'T GET ANY VOTES FROM THE
DEMOCRATS.
INFRASTRUCTURE, WE COULD DO IT
SO EASILY.
THEY ARE SO BUSY INTERVIEWING
HOPE HICKS AND TAKING PICTURES
OF THIS INCREDIBLE YOUNG WOMAN
AND PUTTING THE PICTURES OUT TO
THE PRESS OF HER TESTIFYING.
THEY AREN'T ALLOWED TO DO THAT,
IT'S PROBABLY ILLEGAL.
IT'S A TERRIBLE THING GOING ON.
>> Sean: SIR, THERE HAVE BEEN
FOUR SEPARATE INVESTIGATIONS,
LET REMIND YOU.
THE NINE MONTH FBI
INVESTIGATION, THE ONE THAT
PETER STRZOK SAID THERE'S NO
THERE THERE, DISSIPATE SAID WE
HAD NOTHING AFTER NINE MONTHS AS
IT RELATES TO COLLUSION.
AND THERE WAS A HOUSE INTEL
COMMITTEE INVESTIGATION, THAN A
BIPARTISAN SENATE COMMITTEE, NO
COLLUSION.
THE MUELLER REPORT DIRECTLY
CONCLUDED NO COLLUSION, NO
CONSPIRACY.
I'M A TALK SHOW HOST AND SO I
SOMETIMES DO STRAIGHT NEWS EMMA
WE DO INVESTIGATIVE REPORTING,
SOMETIMES SPORTS AND CULTURE AND
I GIVE A STRONG CONSERVATIVE
OPINIONS, WE DON'T HIDE THAT
FACT.
BUT I WANTED YOU TO DECLASSIFY
THE 302, THE PHIS APPLICATION,
DECLASSIFY THE GANG OF EIGHT,
DECLASSIFY EXCULPATORY
INFORMATION.
YOU HAVE DONE SO BUT YOU GAVE IT
TO THE ATTORNEY GENERAL, WHY?
>> I THINK HE'S A VERY HONORABLE
GENTLEMAN WHO WANTS TO DO THE
RIGHT THING.
HE IS ALLOWED TO UNDER MY
AGREEMENT -- SHE'S ALLOWED TO
GIVE IT OUT TO WHOEVER HE WANTS.
I THINK OTHER COUNTRIES WERE
INVOLVED.
I THINK PERHAPS BASED ON WHAT
I'M SEEING, THEY DON'T WANT TO
GET CAUGHT WHAT THEY WERE DOING
IN THIS COUNTRY -- YOU KNOW THAT
VERY WELL.
ATTORNEY GENERAL BILL BARR, HE'S
GOT IT TOTALLY, EVERYTHING HE
CAN DO IN TERMS OF OPENING IT UP
AND MAKING IT TRANSPARENT AS THE
POLITICIANS LIKE TO USE THAT
WORD, TRANSPARENT.
I'M THE MOST TRANSPARENT
PRESIDENT IN HISTORY.
I LEFT MUELLER HAVE EVERYTHING
THEY WANTED.
500 WITNESSES, INTERVIEW OUR
ATTORNEYS, INTERVIEW WHOEVER YOU
WANT, I THINK 2,500 SUBPOENAS.
I DIDN'T USE PRESIDENTIAL
PRIVILEGE BECAUSE I DIDN'T SPEAK
TO RUSSIA, WHEN I WAS WINNING IS
WISCONSIN, WHEN I WAS WINNING IN
MICHIGAN AND PENNSYLVANIA AND
OHIO AND FLORIDA AND ALL OF
THESE STATES, NORTH CAROLINA,
THE LAST PERSON OR GROUP I EVER
THOUGHT OF CALLING WOULD BE
RUSSIA.
IT'S A HOAX, TERRIBLE HOAX AND
THAT SHOULD NEVER HAPPEN TO
ANOTHER PRESIDENT.
MANY OF THEM WOULD NOT BE ABLE
TO HANDLE IT, I DON'T CARE WHO
THEY ARE.
MANY OF THEM WOULD NOT BE ABLE
TO HANDLE IT.
IF YOU THINK JOE BIDEN COULD
HANDLE IT?
JOE BIDEN RIGHT NOW, HE LOOKS
LIKE HE HAS SOME BIG PROBLEMS.
IF CAN YOU IMAGINE IF THIS
HAPPENED TO JOE BIDEN?
IT WOULD BE GOOD.
IT SHOULD NEVER HAPPEN TO
ANOTHER PRESIDENT WHAT HAPPENED
TO ME AND IT SHOULD NEVER
HAPPEN, NOBODY SHOULD EVER ALLOW
THIS TO GO FORWARD AGAIN.
PEOPLE HAVE TO LEARN THERE HAS
TO BE A LESSON TAUGHT.
THERE HAS TO BE A LESSON TAUGHT,
IT SHOULD NEVER BE ALLOWED.
IT'S SO BAD FOR OUR COUNTRY.
>> Sean: MR. PRESIDENT, I HAVE
A QUESTION ABOUT THIS BECAUSE
YOU DIDN'T INVOKE EXECUTIVE
PRIVILEGE, YOU HANDED IN
1.4 MILLION DOCUMENTS, YOU
ENCOURAGED YOUR STAFF TO
COOPERATE WITH CONGRESS, TO
COOPERATE WITH MUELLER, I NEVER
LIKED MUELLER'S TEAM, I COULD
NOT FOR THE LIFE OF ME
UNDERSTAND HOW HE HIRED
ANDREW WEISSMANN, THE WORST
RECORD OF ANY LAWYER I'VE EVER
SEEN.
PEOPLE LIKE JEANNIE RAE WHO WAS
ONCE CLINTON'S LAWYER ON THE
CLINTON FOUNDATION.
YOU GAVE WRITTEN ANSWERS, YOU
EVEN LET YOUR WHITE HOUSE
COUNSEL DON MCGANN TESTIFY
FOR 30 HOURS.
I WAS SHOCKED, WHY WOULD YOU
ALLOW THAT?
>> I LET EVERYBODY TESTIFY, I
WANTED TO BE TOTALLY OPEN
BECAUSE I KNEW THERE WAS NOTHING
THERE.
THERE WAS NOTHING THERE, NOTHING
AT ALL.
BOB MUELLER WAS CONFLICTED
BECAUSE HE WANTED TO BE THE HEAD
OF THE FBI, THE DIRECTOR AGAIN.
HE WAS ALREADY THERE FOR 10 OR
12 YEARS BUT HE WANTED TO BE AND
I DIDN'T ALLOW THAT, I SAID NO.
I SAID IT RESPECTFULLY.
WE HAD A BUSINESS DISPUTE IN
PRIVATE LIFE WHEN HE WAS OUT OF
THE FBI.
WE HAD A COMMERCIAL BUSINESS
DISPUTE.
THINK OF THIS, HE SUPPOSED TO BE
RULING ON YOU.
IT WAS A BUSINESS DISPUTE AND IT
WAS A NASTY DISPUTE, NOT THE
BIGGEST ONE I'VE EVER BEEN IN TO
BE HONEST WITH YOU BUT WE HAD A
REAL BUSINESS DISPUTE.
YOU LOOK AT THAT, THAT'S A TOTAL
CONFLICT OF INTEREST, HOW CAN
SOMEONE WITH WHOM YOU HAVE A
DISPUTE BE RULING?
AND HIS BEST FRIEND CLOSE TO
WHAT IS COMEY AND HE PLAYED A
BIG PART OF THIS.
BECAUSE McCABE INTO ANYTHING
WITHOUT COMEY.
HE WAS TOTALLY DOMINATED BY
COMEY, ANDREW MCCABE WAS A BAD
GUY.
HE DID NOTHING WITHOUT CALLING
COMEY.
THERE IS AN EXPRESSION, HE
WOULDN'T GO TO THE BATHROOM
WITHOUT GETTING COMEY'S
APPROVAL.
SO COMEY IS IN AND BRANDON, YOU
TAKE A LOOK AT BRENNAN, THE
HORRIBLE RHETORIC, THE HORRIBLE
WORDS HE USED.
>> Sean: HE ACCUSED YOU OF
TREASON.
>> President Trump: AND THEN
HE SAID I GUESS I WAS
MISINFORMED.
HE WAS MAKING ALL THESE
PREDICTIONS AND THEN WHEN THEY
SAID NO COLLUSION IN THE MUELLER
REPORT -- WHICH IS AMAZING, THEY
HAD 18 PEOPLE THAT WERE
HILLARY CLINTON PEOPLE, I THINK
ALL OF THEM WERE ANTI-TRUMP
PEOPLE IN ONE FORM OR ANOTHER
BUT MANY OF THESE PEOPLE, THEY
GAVE TO CLINTON'S CAMPAIGN, ONE
OR TWO OF THEM WERE AT INCLUDING
WEISSMANN WERE AT THE EVENT
WHICH TURNED OUT TO BE HER
WAKE -- IT WAS A FUNERAL.
IT WAS SUPPOSED TO BE A PARTY AT
THE CONVENTION CENTER IN
NEW YORK.
>> Sean: HE WAS AT THE VICTORY
PARTY.
>> President Trump: I SAW THE
SAME SCENE AS YOU DID TO.
BOB MUELLER WAS GREAT FRIENDS
WITH COMEY, RIGHT THERE THERE'S
A CONFLICT.
AND WE HAD A BUSINESS DISPUTE.
I TOLD YOU A LONG TIME AGO, HOW
COULD HE BE DOING THIS?
DESPITE THAT, LET HIM DO IT.
I HAD NOTHING TO DO -- THEY KNOW
THAT, I HAD NOTHING TO DO WITH
RUSSIA, I LOVE OUR COUNTRY.
BY DOING THIS, I'VE SACRIFICED A
LOT.
I HAD A SIMPLE LIFE, A GREAT
COMPANY, EVERYTHING WAS GREAT.
I'VE MADE A TREMENDOUS
DIFFERENCE.
SO MANY PEOPLE COME UP TO ME AND
THEY SAY THANK YOU FOR SAVING
OUR COUNTRY.
AND I USED TO TAKE IT WITH A
GRAIN OF SALT BUT THEY SAID AND
THEY MEAN IT.
THE OTHER DAY I WAS THE
COMMENCEMENT SPEAKER AT THE
AIR FORCE ACADEMY, INCREDIBLE
YOUNG PEOPLE AND I HANDED OUT A
THOUSAND DIPLOMAS TO THE SENIOR
CLASS THERE IT IS A LOT OF
SHAKING HANDS AND SALUTING -- IT
WAS A COUPLE OF HOURS BUT IT WAS
GREAT.
SO MANY YOUNG, BEAUTIFUL PEOPLE,
YOUNG PEOPLE, THE BEGINNING OF
AN INCREDIBLE LIFE, THEY CAME UP
TO ME AND THEY SAID THANK YOU,
SIR, FOR SAVING OUR COUNTRY.
I KNOW EXACTLY WHAT THEY MEAN,
OUR COUNTRY WAS IN BIG TROUBLE
AND WE HAVE TO TURN IN THE RIGHT
DIRECTION.
>> Sean: JUST AS AN ASIDE, YOU
DID HAVE THE CONSTITUTIONAL
AUTHORITY UNDER ARTICLE TWO TO
FIRE MUELLER WHO WOULD'VE BEEN
REPLACED.
>> President Trump: I HAD
ARTICLE TWO POWERS, I COULD'VE
DONE DONE ANYTHING I WANTED, I
DON'T RING IT UP BECAUSE WE
DON'T EVEN GET THERE.
I WOULDN'T EVEN HAVE TO BOTHER
TALKING TO YOU ABOUT ALL THE
OTHER THINGS, I WOULDN'T HAVE TO
TALK TO YOU ABOUT CONFLICTS, I
COULD'VE FIRED MUELLER FOR
CONFLICTS, I COULD'VE FIRED
ANYBODY BUT I DIDN'T WANT TO DO
IT BECAUSE THEY SAID LET IT PLAY
OUT, IT'S A HOAX.
IT'S A DISGRACE.
THEY ARE ALLOWED TO GO FORWARD
WITH INTERVIEWING PEOPLE, HAVING
PEOPLE LIKE HOPE HICKS AND
OTHERS, HAVING TO PAY FOR A NEW
SET OF LAWYERS?
THEY JUST WENT THROUGH IT WITH
THE MUELLER REPORT.
SHE DID NOTHING WRONG.
NOW THEY HAVE TO START PAYING
FOR LAWYERS AGAIN?
THAT'S A DO OVER BECAUSE THE
REPORT WAS TERRIBLE FOR THEM.
YOU'RE NOT ALLOWED TO DO OVERS.
>> Sean: THIS WILL BE THE
FIFTH INVESTIGATION AND YOU ARE
RIGHT, THOSE WASHINGTON LAWYERS
ARE EXPENSIVE.
I HAVE HAD TO HIRE A FEW OF THEM
IN MY DAY.
ONE GOOD QUESTION I WANT
ANSWERED ISN'T IT ITALY,
GREAT BRITAIN, AUSTRALIA, WITH A
OUTSOURCED INTELLIGENCE
GATHERING BY HIGH-RANKING
PEOPLE -- NOT RANK-AND-FILE --
TO SPY ON AMERICAN CITIZENS AND
CIRCUMVENT AMERICAN LAWS?
IT WILL BE A BIG QUESTION.
>> President Trump: AND
UKRAINE, TAKE A LOOK AT UKRAINE.
HOW COME THE FBI DIDN'T TAKE THE
SERVER, JOHN PODESTA TOLD HIM TO
GET OUT.
HOW COME THE FBI DIDN'T TAKE THE
SERVER FROM THE DNC?
THINK ABOUT THAT ONE.
>> Sean: THERE ARE 20 SOME
CANDIDATES, I WANT TO GET YOUR
GENERAL THOUGHTS ON ALL OF THEM
AND IS THERE ANYONE IN
PARTICULAR YOU PREFER TO RUN
AGAINST, DO YOU CARE AT ALL?
>> President Trump: WE HAVE TO
SEE HOW IT PLAYS OUT.
I LOOK AT SOME OF THEM, I DON'T
SEE GEORGE WASHINGTON, I DON'T
SEE CHURCHILL, I DON'T SEE
ANYBODY IN PARTICULAR THAT I
WORRY ABOUT.
I THINK HONESTLY, HOWEVER IT IS,
IT IS.
>> Sean: I DON'T SEE
GEORGE WASHINGTON EITHER.
>> President Trump: YOU SEE
THE POLLS WHO CAME OUT TODAY, WE
HAD LEGITIMATE POLLS THAT CAME
OUT TODAY, NOT THE POLLS THE
MEDIA MAKES UP.
I'M FIGHTING THE DEMOCRATS IN
THE MEDIA TOGETHER.
AND YOU KNOW THAT BETTER THAN
ALMOST ANYBODY.
THE PEOPLE KNOW THAT.
I'M FIGHTING THE DEMOCRAT PARTY
AND I'M FIGHTING THE MEDIA, THEY
ARE PARTNERS.
THAT'S WHY THEY DON'T GO AFTER
HILLARY CLINTON WITH HER
EMAILS -- ANYBODY ELSE WOULD BE
IN JAIL FOR WHAT SHE DID COME OF
THE EMAILS, TO DELETE 33,000
EMAILS AFTER -- NOT BEFORE --
AFTER YOU GET A SUBPOENA FROM
CONGRESS, YOU DELETE EVERYTHING
SO PEOPLE NEVER GOT TO SEE THEM.
THE MEDIA AND THE DEMOCRATS --
NOT ALL OF IT BUT A BIG PORTION
OF IT, THEY ARE A PARTNERSHIP.
THAT'S DISGRACEFUL.
I'M FIGHTING THE PARTNERSHIP.
FIGHTING THE MEDIA IS MUCH
TOUGHER THAN FIGHTING THE
DEMOCRATS IF YOU WANT TO KNOW
THE TRUTH.
>> Sean: I CALL THEM THE MEDIA
MOB.
I SAY IT EVERY SECOND, EVERY
MINUTE, EVERY HOUR OF EVERY DAY
AND THEY ALL LIED AND THEY ALL
FELL FOR THE HOAX IN THE
CONSPIRACY THEORY AND THEY ARE
TRYING TO REVISIT IT.
>> President Trump: THEY
DIDN'T FALL FOR THE HOAX, THEY
KNOW IT'S A HOAX, THESE ARE VERY
SMART PEOPLE.
THEY KNOW IT'S A HOAX.
AND THEY RIGHT ABOUT IT ANYWAY.
I WATCH WHEN I HAVE TO TO GET
AMMUNITION, YOU HAVE TO KNOW
WHERE THE OTHER SIDE IS COMING
FROM.
I WATCH EVERY ONCE IN A WHILE, I
WILL TURN TO MSNBC AND I'LL SEE
WHAT THEY SAY.
I KNOW MOST OF THE PEOPLE AND
IT'S A FRAUD.
THEY GO BACK AND THEY MEET AND
WHAT CAN WE MAKE UP?
EVERYONE USED THE WORD
MANUFACTURED AND EVERY NEWSCAST
HAD THE WORD MANUFACTURED BUT
IT'S NOT A WORD ASSOCIATED WITH
WHAT THEY WERE TALKING ABOUT.
THEY WERE TALKING ABOUT
SOMETHING BEING MANUFACTURED.
EVERY NEWSCAST STARTED WITH
"MANUFACTURED."
THEY COME UP WITH A WORD THEY
PUT IT OUT.
IT'S A DISGRACEFUL SITUATION.
HERE'S THE GOOD NEWS: , WE ARE
PRESIDENT, WE'VE DONE IT, WE'RE
GOING TO DO IT AGAIN.
NO ONE HAS SEEN CROWDS LIKE
THAT, NO ONE HAS SEEN THE SPIRIT
AND THE ENERGY, IT HAS BEEN
INCREDIBLE.
I SAID REPUBLICANS HAVE FAR MORE
ENERGY -- YOU HEAR ABOUT THE
ENERGY ON THE DEMOCRAT SIDE,
THEY DON'T HAVE ENERGY, THEY ARE
ALL FIGHTING WITH EACH OTHER.
REPUBLICANS HAVE FAR MORE ENERGY
THAN THE DEMOCRATS, I BELIEVE
THAT.
>> Sean: A FEW OF THESE
REPUBLICANS COULD USE A SPINE
TRANSPLANT IN MY VIEW.
>> President Trump: I AGREE
BUT WE HAVE SOME GREAT ONES TOO.
BUT YOU ARE RIGHT, THERE ARE
SOME -- NANCY PELOSI HANDS OUT
SUBPOENAS LIKE THEY ARE COOKIES.
PAUL RYAN, NICE GUY BUT I WILL
TELL YOU WHEN JIM, MARK MEADOWS,
DEVON, ALL THESE PEOPLE, THEY
ARE GREAT PEOPLE WHEN THEY WENT
TO PAUL RYAN TO GET A SUBPOENA
BECAUSE THEY FOUND THE SAME
THINGS THAT WE ARE TALKING
ABOUT, PAUL WOULD SAY LET'S TAKE
IT EASY, LET'S COME BACK IN A
WEEK, LET'S SEE IF WE STILL
THINK -- LET'S DO THIS, IT WAS
IMPOSSIBLE.
YOU CAN GET A SUBPOENA.
SHE HANDS OUT SUBPOENAS LIKE
THEY ARE COOKIES.
IT'S A BIG DIFFERENCE.
THEY FIGHT A DIRTY OR FIGHT, THE
DEMOCRATS BY THE DIRTY OR FIGHT,
IT'S TOO BAD.
>> Sean: THE DEMOCRAT DEBATES
BEGIN NEXT WEEK, THEY'RE
SUPPORTING THIS NEW GREEN DEAL,
THEY WANT TO GET RID OF THE
LIFEBLOOD OF OUR ECONOMY, OIL
AND GAS.
EVERYTHING IS GOING TO BE FREE.
THEY ARE TALKING ABOUT A 70% TOP
MARGINAL TAX RATE FOR
INDIVIDUALS, 90% TOP MARGINAL
RATE FOR BUSINESSES AND A WEALTH
TAX ON TOP OF THAT.
AND WHEN YOU DIE YOU HAVE TO PAY
A TAX.
AND EVERYTHING IS FREE.
THEY ALL SEEM TO SUPPORT SOME
VERSION OF IT AND MEDICARE FOR
ALL.
YOU CAN'T BUY PRIVATE INSURANCE
ACCORDING TO KAMALA HARRIS, HOW
DID OBAMACARE WORK OUT FOR
EVERYBODY?
WHAT IS YOUR REACTION TO THIS
AGENDA?
>> President Trump: WITH
OBAMACARE WE TOOK OUT THE
INDIVIDUAL MANDATE WHICH IS THE
WORST PART.
OBAMACARE IS A DISASTER AND WE
MANAGED REALLY WELL.
WE'VE REALLY DONE A GREAT JOB.
IT'S INCREDIBLE THE WAY THEY
HANDLED OBAMACARE.
I GOT RID OF THE INDIVIDUAL
MANDATE WHICH WAS THE WORST
THING IN OBAMACARE.
YOU PAY FOR THE PRIVILEGE OF NOT
HAVING TO PAY FOR INSURANCE, BAD
HEALTH CARE.
IT'S ONE OF THOSE THINGS.
I THINK WHEN I MEET SOMEBODY WHO
EVEN DOESN'T LIKE ME, LET'S SAY
IT'S A BUSINESS PERSON AND THEY
ARE TO TRUMP FANS, THEY SAY YOU
HAVE NO CHOICE COME YOU CAN'T
VOTE FOR ANYBODY ELSE BECAUSE
THEY WANT TO TURN THIS COUNTRY
OVER TWO -- WE WILL BE A
VENEZUELA, IT WILL TAKE TEN
YEARS OR 15 YEARS BUT IF THE
WRONG PERSON GOT IN, I'VE TURNED
IT AROUND.
I'VE GOTTEN RID OF THESE RULES
AND REGULATIONS THAT STIFLED
EVERYTHING.
I APPROVED THE KEYSTONE
PIPELINE, I APPROVED NUMEROUS
OTHER PIPELINES.
THEY ARE ENVIRONMENTALLY GOOD AS
OPPOSED TO TRAINS RUNNING ACROSS
THE PLAINS -- I APPROVED SO MANY
DIFFERENT THINGS THAT ARE
ACTUALLY GOOD TO.
A REPORT CAME OUT, OUR WATER AND
OUR AIR TODAY IS CLEANER THAN IT
EVER WAS.
BECAUSE IN MANY RESPECTS, WE ARE
GREAT ENVIRONMENTALISTS.
I'M AN ENVIRONMENTALIST!
A DIFFERENT KIND, A REAL
ENVIRONMENTALIST.
OUR WATER IS CRYSTAL CLEAN, OUR
AIR, IT'S THE BEST THAT EVER
WAS.
>> Sean: WE ALL NEED TO BE
GOOD STEWARDS OF THE GREATEST
COUNTRY GOD GAVE MAN.
ARE YOU REALLY GOING TO LIVE
TWEET THESE DEMOCRATIC DEBATES?
>> President Trump: I WASN'T
GOING TO BUT I READ ABOUT IN
"THE WALL STREET JOURNAL," IT'S
FAKE NEWS.
I WASN'T THINKING ABOUT IT,
MAYBE I WILL NOW.
MIGHT AS WELL MAKE THEM RIGHT.
>> Sean: I AM A "YES," I THINK
IT WOULD BE A GREAT IDEA.
>> President Trump: THEY WROTE
ABOUT IT AS THOUGH IT WAS FACT,
I NEVER EVEN THOUGHT ABOUT IT
BUT MAYBE I'LL DO IT.
INSTEAD OF FAKE NEWS, I WILL
MAKE THEM CORRECT NEWS AND
THAT'S OKAY.
>> Sean: I THINK IT WOULD BE A
GOOD IDEA, VERY INTERESTING.
I SEE THAT YOU PROMISED ICE NEXT
WEEK WILL BEGIN THE PROCESS OF
REMOVING MILLIONS OF PEOPLE THAT
DIDN'T RESPECT OUR LAWS,
BORDERS, SOVEREIGNTY, 90% OF THE
HEROIN IN THIS COUNTRY COMES
ACROSS OUR SOUTHERN BORDER.
FENTANYL, WE ARE LOSING 300
PEOPLE A WEEK.
MY QUESTION TO YOU AS THERE ARE
SOME PEOPLE WHO ASKED ABOUT YOU
AND THEY WILL SAY YOU'VE KNOWN
HIM FOR OVER TWO DECADES, I'VE
KNOWN YOU A LONG TIME.
YOU SAID HE WOULD BE
CONSERVATIVE AND YOU ARE RIGHT
AND WE DIDN'T BELIEVE YOU AND
YOU ARE PRO-LIFE AND
CONSERVATIVE JUSTICES AND TAX
CUTS AND THE REGULATION, ENERGY
INDEPENDENCE, ALL THINGS I
BELIEVED IN 30 YEARS IN MEDIA.
NOW YOU'RE FIGHTING FOR THE
BORDER WALL AND PEOPLE SAY MAYBE
DONALD TRUMP SHOULD MAYBE TWEET
A LITTLE LESS AND NOT FIGHT SO
MUCH ON THE PERSONAL LEVEL BUT
YET TAKE THE FIGHT AGAINST
CHINA, AGAINST MEXICO, YOU ARE
STANDING ALONE SAYING YOU HIT
THEM WITH TARIFFS IF THEY DIDN'T
STOP THESE MIGRATIONS FROM
HAPPENING.
MY QUESTION TO YOU IS HOW DO YOU
RESPOND TO THAT?
PEOPLE WANT YOU TO TURN OFF THE
SWITCH, YOU FIGHT FOR THE
BORDERS, YOU FIGHT FOR YOUR
AGENDA BUT THEY DON'T WANT YOU
TO FIGHT ON TWITTER.
>> President Trump: I DON'T
USE THE WORD TWITTER, I SAY
SOCIAL MEDIA.
IF I DON'T USE SOCIAL MEDIA COME
OUTSIDE OF YOU AND A FEW OTHER
GREAT PEOPLE, I CALL THEM
PATRIOTS.
YOU'RE NOT REALLY PATRIOTS AS
MUCH IS YOU WANT RATINGS.
YOU GIVE ME GREAT RATINGS, LAST
NIGHT YOU HAVE TREMENDOUS -- I
HEARD THE SPEECH.
THAT WAS AN EASY NIGHT, YOU AND
TUCKER AND EVERYONE ELSE SAID
LET'S DO IT AND YOU DID IT.
IT WAS A GREAT EVENING.
I VIEW IT AS A SOCIAL MEDIA, A
WAY OF GETTING THE WORD OUT.
WHEN YOU HAVE THE LIES AND THE
FRAUDS COMMITTED BY THE OTHER
NETWORKS, MANY OF THE OTHER
NETWORKS, YOU LOOK AT WHAT'S
GOING ON, IT'S DISGRACEFUL.
THIS WAY I GET THE WORD OUT AND
I'M GETTING IT OUT STRONGLY.
I HAVE HUNDREDS OF MILLIONS OF
PEOPLE THAT SEE THIS, PLUS AS
SOON AS I DO IT TWEET IT GETS
BROADCAST EVEN IN THE PLACES YOU
WOULD LEAST EXPECT IT BECAUSE
THEY ARE DESPERATE FOR NEWS.
IT'S REALLY A WAY OF GETTING THE
TRUTH OUT BECAUSE THE MEDIA HAS
GONE LOCO, THEY HAVE LOST ALL
CONTROL.
THEY DON'T EVEN CALL A PERFECT
CHECK.
I REMEMBER TEN YEARS AGO, 15
YEARS AGO -- I ACTUALLY USED TO
GET GREAT PRESS.
BEFORE I DECIDE TO BECOME A
POLITICIAN AND ONE ON THE
CONSERVATIVE BASIS BECAUSE
THAT'S WHAT IT IS.
THAT'S WHAT WE ARE DOING SO WELL
AT.
PROBABLY DOING BETTER RIGHT NOW
IN OUR ECONOMY, WAGES ARE UP,
HAVEN'T GONE UP IN YEARS, IN
DECADES.
WAGES ARE UP OVER 3%, THE THINGS
THAT HAVE HAPPENED IN JOBS,
UNEMPLOYMENT, THE AMOUNT OF
PEOPLE WORKING, COMPANIES ARE
POURING BACK INTO OUR COUNTRY
FROM JAPAN.
THEY'RE COMING BACK FROM CHINA
BECAUSE I PUT THE TARIFFS ON.
THEY ARE COMING BACK INTO THIS
COUNTRY, THE WAY I GET THE WORD
OUT IS THROUGH SOCIAL MEDIA.
I DON'T KNOW THAT I WOULD'VE
BEEN SUCCESSFUL IF I DIDN'T HAVE
IT.
THERE WAS A FANTASTIC WOMAN IN
THE FRONT WHO SAID PLEASE KEEP
TWEETING, IT MATTERS.
I THINK IT DOES MATTER.
I DON'T DO IT BECAUSE I ENJOY
IT, I DO IT BECAUSE WHEN SOMEONE
SAYS AN OUTRIGHT LIE ON MSNBC OR
CNN, BOTH OF WHOM ARE REALLY
SUFFERING IN THE RATINGS WHICH
IS REALLY INTERESTING -- IT'S
INCREDIBLE.
THEY HAVE LOST CREDIBILITY.
WHEN THEY PUT OUT LIES, I CAN
COUNTERACT THOSE LIES AND HAVE
MANY MORE FOLLOWERS THAN THEY
DO.
>> Sean: LET ME ASK YOU, YOU
SAID YOU WERE GOING TO BEGIN THE
PROCESS OF REMOVING MILLIONS OF
ILLEGAL IMMIGRANTS.
I WANT TO GET TO THE STATUS OF
THE BORDER WALL.
THERE HAS BEEN MILES REPAIRED
AND MILES BUILT.
IS IT GOING TO BE FINISHED WITH
YOUR FIRST TERM?
THEY WEREN'T ABLE TO OVERRIDE
YOUR VETO AND YOU WERE ABLE TO
REALLOCATE FUNDS.
SPACEX THE DEMOCRATS ARE DOING
EVERYTHING POSSIBLE TO STOP THE
WALL.
THEY LOST A BIG LAWSUIT LAST
WEEK, I WON A BIG LAWSUIT
AGAINST NANCY PELOSI IN THE
HOUSE.
THE HOUSE BROUGHT A LAWSUIT,
NANCY PELOSI BROUGHT A LAWSUIT.
AND WE WON THE LAWSUIT AS YOU
PROBABLY READ.
WE HAVE FOUR OTHER LAWSUITS
AGAINST US, ALL SEMIRELATED AND
RELATED TO EACH OTHER.
WE ARE BUILDING A TREMENDOUS
WALL RIGHT NOW, WE ARE
RENOVATING VAST AREAS OF WALL
THAT COLLAPSED BUT IT'S GOOD IF
YOU RENOVATE CAN YOU SAVE A LOT
OF MONEY BY RENOVATING IT.
WE ARE TAKING DOWN THE WALL AND
PUTTING UP NEW WALL, SOME AREAS
YOU CAN'T RENOVATE.
WE WILL HAVE OVER 400 MILES OF
WALL BUILT BY THE END OF NEXT
YEAR WHICH IS VERY QUICK.
WE HAVE THREE SECTIONS BEING
BUILT RIGHT NOW, WE ARE BUILDING
THEM IN SECTIONS IN DIFFERENT
AREAS IN DIFFERENT STATES.
NEW MEXICO HAS A TREMENDOUS
PROBLEM WITH PEOPLE POURING
ACROSS NEW MEXICO I'M HEARING
BECAUSE OF THIS, NEW MEXICO IS
IN PLAY FOR ME AND THE
REPUBLICANS.
IT'S HORRIBLE WHAT'S HAPPENING.
WE HAVE SECTIONS THAT STARTED
AND ARE ABOUT TO START IN
NEW MEXICO.
WE JUST FINISHED SAN DIEGO, THEY
ARE SO HAPPY.
THE MAYOR IS IN MY OFFICE, A
GREAT GUY.
HE CAME UP TO THANK ME FOR
HAVING DONE THE WALL BECAUSE HAS
MADE SUCH A DIFFERENCE.
HE SAYS IT'S LIKE DAY AND NIGHT.
PEOPLE ARE FLOWING ACROSS AND
NOW NOBODY CAN COME IN.
WE ARE ABLE TO REDESIGN THE WALL
WHERE IT'S STRONGER, BIGGER,
HIGHER, AT ACTUALLY GOT A LITTLE
BIT HIGHER IF YOU REMEMBER THAT.
IT COST LESS MONEY.
WE ARE DOING REALLY WELL WITH
THE WALL AND IT'S A VERY
IMPORTANT ELEMENT AND WE ARE
DOING WELL OVERALL.
WE ARE GOING TO START REMOVING
ALL OF THESE PEOPLE WHO CAME IN
BECAUSE THE DEMOCRATS WILL NOT
UNDER ANY CIRCUMSTANCES, THEY
WON'T FIX ASYLUM -- ASYLUM IS A
BIG PROBLEM.
WE COULD FIX IT IN 15 MINUTES
AND THEY WON'T GET RID OF THE
LOOPHOLES BECAUSE THEY WANT US
TO FAIL.
IT'S MORE IMPORTANT THAT WE
FAILED IN THE COUNTRY SUCCEED.
YOU HAVE DRUGS IN ALL THE OTHER
THINGS.
WHAT WE ARE DOING IS AS THE
PEOPLE COME UP AND AS WE GET THE
NECESSARY PAPERWORK, WE ARE
MOVING PEOPLE OUT OF THE INNARDS
OF THE COUNTRY AND WE ARE
BRINGING THEM BACK.
THE COUNTRIES THAT SEE THIS AND
THEY SEE IT HAPPENING, IT IS
ALREADY STARTED ON A MUCH
HEAVIER FASHION NEXT WEEK.
IT'S SENDING A SIGNAL THAT YOU
MAKE IT THEN BUT YOU'RE NOT
GETTING IN FOR LONG AND YOU ARE
GOING OUT.
THE OTHER THING FINALLY IS
MEXICO FOR THE FIRST TIME EVER,
IN MANY, MANY DECADES, THEY ARE
RESPECTING US.
WE HAD A BIG FIGHT AND IT WORKED
OUT GREAT.
6,000 SOLDIERS ON THE SOUTHERN
BORDER COME ON THEIR SOUTHERN
BORDER.
STOPPING PEOPLE FROM COMING IN.
THEY HAVE BEEN REALLY STEPPING
IT UP.
I WAS GOING TO PUT TARIFFS ON IF
THEY DIDN'T.
IF THEY DIDN'T I WOULD'VE PUT
TARIFFS ON.
THEY HAVE BEEN DOING A REALLY
GOOD JOB AND PEOPLE ON THE
BORDER WILL TELL YOU THE TRAFFIC
HAS REALLY DROPPED DOWN.
A LOT OF GOOD THINGS ARE
HAPPENING.
BUT IF THE DEMOCRATS WOULD MEET
FOR 20 MINUTES, 15 MINUTES, IT
USED TO BE 45 -- IT'S A VERY
SHORT MEETING.
WE COULD SOLVE THE BORDER
PROBLEM BUT THEY DON'T WANT TO
DO THAT BECAUSE THEY THINK IT'S
BAD POLITICALLY.
I THINK WHAT IS BAD, WHAT IS
REALLY BAD AS WHAT THEY ARE
DOING, I THINK IT'S TERRIBLE.
PEOPLE COME IN, IT'S A CRIME, AS
DRUGS, WE CAN STOP IT ALSO FAST
BUT WE ARE GOING TO STOP IT
ANYWAY EVEN IF WE DON'T HAVE THE
DEMOCRATS.
>> Sean: I SAY NANCY PELOSI IS
SPEAKER IN NAME -- CONGRESSWOMAN
ALEXANDRIA OCASIO-CORTEZ IS THE
BIGGEST STAR, SHE GOT TO
JOE BIDEN TO COME UP WITH A NEW
GREEN NEW DEAL PLAN.
WHAT ARE YOUR THOUGHTS ON HER
AND CONGRESSWOMAN ILHAN OMAR IN
THE POSITION THAT NANCY PELOSI
IS IN.
>> President Trump: I THINK
NANCY PELOSI PROBABLY HAS
CONTROL OF IT, I HEAR DIFFERENT
THINGS BUT I THINK SHE DOES.
SHE KNOWS WHAT SHE'S DOING.
WE WILL SEE HOW IT ALL COMES OU
OUT.
WE HAVE THE USMCA, THE MEXICO
AND CANADA TRADE DEAL WHICH IS A
PHENOMENAL DEAL FOR OUR COUNTRY
AND IT'S GOOD FOR THEM TOO.
IT'S A PHENOMENAL DEAL FOR OUR
FARMERS AND MANUFACTURERS AND
EVEN UNIONS.
EVERYONE WANTS IT, THE DEMOCRATS
COULD DO THAT IN A BIPARTISAN
WAY.
MEXICO APPROVED IT TODAY, YOU
PROBABLY HEARD THEY JUST
APPROVED IT.
WE'RE JUST WAITING TO SEE
WHETHER OR NOT THEY WILL PUT
THAT UP FOR A VOTE.
CAN YOU IMAGINE IF THEY DID?
IT WILL BE A VERY BIPARTISAN
APPROVAL.
NANCY AND ALL OF THE FOLKS IN
THE HOUSE THEY HAVE TO PUT IT UP
FOR A BOAT AND THEY WILL VOTE,
GREAT FOR THE FARMERS, EVERYONE
WANTS THEM TO DO IT.
WE WILL SEE, AGAIN -- DO THEY
WANT TO DO WHAT'S RIGHT FOR THE
PARTY?
THEY CAN TAKE CREDIT FOR THAT
BILL, MAKE IT BIPARTISAN WE WILL
ALL VOTE FOR IT.
CANADA IS APPROVING IT, MEXICO
IS APPROVING IT, A VERY BIG DEA
DEAL.
IT MEANS HUNDREDS OF BILLIONS OF
DOLLARS TO OUR COUNTRY AND
THOUSANDS AND THOUSANDS OF JOBS.
IT REPLACES NAFTA, ONE OF THE
WORST TRADE DEALS EVER MADE.
>> Sean: LET ME ASK YOU ABOUT
FOREIGN POLICY, YOU MADE
PROMISES TO ISRAEL, JERUSALEM IS
NOW.
YOU RECOGNIZE GOAL      THE GOLN
YOU RECOGNIZE GOAL      THE GOLH
YOU RECOGNIZE GOAL      THE GOLI
YOU RECOGNIZE GOAL      THE GOLS
YOU RECOGNIZE GOAL      THE GOL,
YOU PROMISED TO GET US OUT OF
THE IRANI AND DALE, I DON'T
THINK YOU'RE GOING TO DROP
$150 BILLION IN CASH AND OTHER
CURRENCY ON THE TARMAC OF
MULLAHS WHO CHANT DEATH TO
AMERICA -- I WORRY ABOUT IRANIAN
HEGEMONY AND PROXY WARS AND
TERROR, I WORRY ABOUT THEIR
ALLIANCE WITH VLADIMIR PUTIN AND
I'M NOT SURE WHERE CHINA SHAKES
OUT IN ALL OF THIS AS YOU LOOK
AT THE GEOPOLITICAL WORKUP,
IRAN, RUSSIA, CHINA, TELL ME
YOUR CONCERNS.
SPACEX DON'T WORRY ABOUT A
THING, EVERYTHING IS UNDER
CONTROL.
YOU ARE RIGHT, WE DID THAT FOR
ISRAEL, AS YOU KNOW EVERY
PRESIDENT SAID YOU GOT TO MOVE
THE EMBASSY TO JERUSALEM, IT
BECOMES THE CAPITAL OF ISRAEL,
EVERY PRESIDENT SAID WE ARE
GOING TO DO IT, NONE OF THEM DID
IT, I DID IT.
THE GOLAN HEIGHTS, FOR 50 YEARS
THEY TALKED ABOUT THE
GOLAN HEIGHTS, I DID IT.
I UNDERSTAND, THIS LED PEOPLE
BEGGING YOU NOT TO DO IT FOR
OTHER COUNTRIES, HEADS OF
COUNTRIES BUT ALL PRESIDENTS
SAID THEY WERE GOING TO DO
GOLAN HEIGHTS, THEY WERE GOING
TO DO JERUSALEM, THEY DIDN'T DO
IT AND TERMINATED ONE OF THE
WORST DEALS EVER MADE, THE IRAN
DEAL THAT WAS MADE BY
PRESIDENT OBAMA, PAID
150 BILLION, 1.8 BILLION IN CAS
CASH.
IRAN IS A MUCH DIFFERENT
COUNTRY.
I WILL TELL YOU MUCH DIFFERENT
TODAY THAN WHEN I TOOK OVER.
WHEN I TOOK OVER IT LOOK LIKE
THERE WAS NO STOPPING THEM.
>> Sean: CAN YOU SAY THEY WILL
NEVER GET NUKES?
>> President Trump: IF I WERE
YOU, DON'T WORRY ABOUT A THING.
>> Sean: WHAT ABOUT PUTIN AND
CHINA?
>> President Trump: THEY WERE
FORCED TOGETHER BY
PRESIDENT OBAMA, YOU NEVER LIKE
TO SEE THAT WHAT THEY WERE
FORCED TOGETHER BY HIS ATTITUDE
AND WHAT THEY DID.
WHEN I GOT HERE, THEY WERE
GETTING VERY CLOSE.
WE ARE DOING THINGS THAT NOBODY
WILL BE ABLE TO COMPETE WITH.
SECOND OF ALL, WE WILL HAVE A
GOOD RELATIONSHIP WITH RUSSIA
AND WE WILL HAVE A GOOD
RELATIONSHIP WITH CHINA, THEY
ARE POWERFUL NATIONS AND WE ARE
A VERY POWERFUL NATION.
I'VE REBUILT OUR MILITARY,
$716 BILLION LAST YEAR, IT WAS
DEPLETED.
THEY HAD PLANS THAT WERE SO OLD,
THEY COULDN'T FLY.
OUR MILITARY IS ALMOST COMPLETED
IN TERMS OF BEING REBUILT.
WE ARE DOING MISSILE
DO WE ANNOUNCE IT OR DO WE NOT
ANNOUNCE IT?
WE HAVE TREMENDOUS -- THE LEVELS
OF SOPHISTICATION LIKE YOU'VE
NEVER SEEN.
WITH ALL OF THAT BEING SAID, I
WANT TO GET ALONG WITH RUSSIA,
AND I THINK WE WILL.
I WANT TO GET ALONG WITH CHINA,
I'M EATING ACTUALLY BOTH OF THEM
NEXT WEEK IN JAPAN.
THE UNITED STATES GETS ALONG --
THE RUSSIAN WITCH HUNTER REALLY
HURT US IN TERMS OF OUR
RELATIONSHIP WITH RUSSIA.
IN TERMS OF RELATIONSHIP WITH A
LOT OF PEOPLE, BUT WE HAVE VERY
GOOD RELATIONSHIPS WITH
COUNTRIES, AND SOMETIMES
COUNTRIES YOU WOULDN'T THINK SO,
BECAUSE I'VE SAID, YOU HAVE TO
PAY FOR NATO, THE UNITED STATES
IS PAYING FOR NATO.
YOU HAVE A LOT OF COUNTRIES THAT
WERE DELINQUENT IN THEIR
PAYMENTS TO NATO.
I GOT THEM TO PAY OVER HUNDREDS
OF BILLIONS OF DOLLARS TOWARD
NATO, BUT I THINK WE ARE GOING
TO GET ALONG WITH A LOT OF
COUNTRIES, BUT THOSE TWO IN
PARTICULAR, I THINK WE WILL HAVE
A GOOD RELATIONSHIP.
BUT WE ARE A VERY STRONG
COUNTRY, AND WE ARE RESPECTED
AGAIN, SEAN.
>> Sean: I HATE TO INTERRUPT
YOU, BUT I ACTUALLY TOOK
15 MINUTES OF LAURA INGRAHAM'S
SHOW.
>> President Trump: I KNOW
THAT, LAURA MUST NOT BE HAPPY
RIGHT NOW.
>> Sean: IT'S HER BIRTHDAY
TODAY, SIR.
>> President Trump: SHE'S A
GREAT PERSON PAIRED >> Sean:
THANK YOU FOR BEING WITH US.
HAPPY BIRTHDAY FOR ME.
I THINK THE PRESIDENT WOULD LIKE
TO WISH YOU A HAPPY BIRTHDAY.
>> Laura: HEY, MR. PRESIDENT.
>> President Trump: THANK YOU,
HAPPY BIRTHDAY.
WE'VE KNOWN EACH OTHER A LONG
TIME, AND CONGRATULATIONS ON
YOUR SHOW.
IT'S A BIG SUCCESS, LAURA, BIG
SUCCESS.
>> Laura: I APPRECIATE IT.
TANK YOU, MR. PRESIDENT.
IF YOU WANT TO STAY ON FOR
ANOTHER COUPLE MINUTES, THAT'S
FINE, BUT I DON'T WANT TO TAKE
HANNITY'S INTERVIEW.
>> President Trump: IT'S THE
BATON, WE HAND OFF TO LAURA.
HE >> Laura: ALL RIGHT,
MR. PRESIDENT  --
>> President Trump: THANK YOU
BOTH.
YOUR GREAT PATRIOT, YOU LOVE OUR
COUNTRY, I APPRECIATE IT, AND SO
DOES EVERYONE ELSE.
THEY DO APPRECIATE IT.
THEY REALLY GET IT.
THE PEOPLE OF THIS COUNTRY, THEY
GET IT.
THEY ARE SMART.
>> Laura: MR. PRESIDENT, DID
YOU GET BRIEFED ON THIS SYRIAN
ATTACK OR PLANNED ATTACK ON A
CHRISTIAN CHURCH IN PITTSBURGH
YET?
NEWS BROKE THIS EVENING --
>> President Trump: I HAVE
BEEN TOLD ABOUT IT AND LITTLE
DETAIL, I WILL MEET A LITTLE
LATER ABOUT IT, ACTUALLY,
TONIGHT.